TEN YEARS AT THE HELM RIGHT HERE
AT "SPECIAL REPORT."
>> BRET BAIER, NOT ONLY ARE YOU
GRADED WHAT YOU DO EVERY SINGLE
NIGHT ON "SPECIAL REPORT," BUT I
KNOW YOU.
I KNOW THE PERSON.
I KNOW YOUR FAMILY.
I KNOW YOUR KIDS.
TEN WONDERFUL, SUCCESSFUL YEARS.
YOU'RE ONLY 13 YEARS BEHIND ME.
YOU'VE GOT A LITTLE BIT OF
CATCHING UP TO DO.
BUT WE ARE PROUD OF YOU.
CONGRATULATIONS FOR ALL YOUR
GREAT SUCCESS AND THE WONDERFUL
JOB YOU DO INFORMING PEOPLE EACH
AND EVERY NIGHT RIGHT HERE ON
THE FOX NEWS CHANNEL.
>> YOU TOOK OVER AT
"SPECIAL REPORT."
>> WELCOME TO WASHINGTON.
I'M BRET BAIER.
>> FOR TEN YEARS, YOU'VE DONE A
FANTASTIC JOB LEADING THE WAY.
BREAKING NEWS, TOP INTERVIEWS.
YOUR WORK ETHIC AND COMMITMENT